today we're talking about next Fortress
fault and Cloud ekm I'm bacola and
welcome to this week in Cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news
we loved hosting Google Cloud next 2022
last week in cities all around the world
and are excited to share our favorite
moments and announcements be sure to
catch the replays Keynotes and more over
the past two years the general
population has become more familiar with
cryptocurrencies and the first iteration
of nfts as some of the earliest use
cases for blockchain technology
this has led to a growing interest in
and demand for web 3 Technologies at the
Enterprise level
with the Fortress fault on Google Cloud
we have the capability to ensure the
Integrity of non-public data while
making it accessible via nfts this is a
game changer for web 3 adoption and
every industry can benefit from the
ability to tokenize assets on blockchain
technology without leaving The Trusted
safety of Google cloud data storage head
to the blog for more
for a variety of reasons the evolution
of cloud computing has led organizations
to want even more control over their
data and more transparency from their
cloud services and at Google Cloud one
of the best tools for achieving that
level of control and transparency is a
bit of technological magic we call Cloud
external key manager ekm Cloud ekm can
help you protect your cloud data at rest
with encryption Keys which are stored
and managed in a third party key
management system that's outside of
Google Cloud's infrastructure and
ultimately outside of Google's control
this can help you achieve full
separation between your encryption keys
and your data stored in the cloud learn
more on this blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud